[Music]
Elle has an adorable relationship with
Lea and a crazy romance with Noah in the
kissing booth these stars have just as
much fun with each other in front of the
camera as they do behind the scenes wait
until the end to see how the IRL couple
are the cutest when celebrating
birthdays if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up here's the kissing booth
behind the scenes and cutest moments
follower festivities one reason we can't
get enough of a cast from the kissing
booth is that they seem so down to earth
Joey King celebration for reaching 1
million 2 million and 3 million
followers really illustrated her
appreciation and gratitude for the love
and support of her fans after reaching 1
million followers King posted a video of
herself trying to do the worm and doing
a celebratory dance that was hilarious
it makes it easy for fans to want to
support her success when her excitement
is so obvious at 2 million followers
King donated blood to commemorate the
occasion in her Instagram post King
acknowledged the purpose of having a
platform by saying she wanted to pass on
the love she received from fans by
donating blood and saving at least 3
lives she also encouraged fans to do the
same hiking in Hollywood we couldn't get
enough of the love story between L and
Noah when it was on-screen and now
they're off-screen IRL romance has fans
going wild since the couple met while
filming the kissing booth a lot of their
adorable couple photos are based on some
of our favorite scenes joey king posted
on twitter that the cast really did get
to film at the hollywood sign as one of
their few l.a locations the couple did
not miss the opportunity to snap an
adorable couple pic that makes it seem
like they were on a casual date hiking
to the sign it makes it clear that their
on-screen and off-screen chemistry is
off the charts since the movie was shot
in South Africa the cast really got to
travel the world together night shoot
nonsense
while the kissing booth cast seemed to
genuinely enjoy their time together
there's no questioning that long days
can drag you down it's clear that Jacob
allure D and Joey King had to find a way
to keep the good times going when the
work grind struggle was real in an
Instagram post
Joey is standing with each foot in an
orange construction cone
Joey posted that she and Jacob resorted
to some pretty weird tactics during
their night shoots to keep themselves
awake and entertained not only did they
keep themselves entertained but they
gave fans a glimpse into why these two
makes such a fun couple they're clearly
able to goof off together and enjoy each
other sense of humor learning how to
solve a Rubik's Cube the cast of the
kissing booth definitely bonded together
quickly their social media posts shows
fans that their friendship is not only
reserved for their characters and we
love getting behind the scenes sneak
peeks one of these cute instances is
between joey king jacob oh lordy and
Joshua Edie in the video which is
clearly between takes since the stars
are still dressed as their characters
joey is explaining how to get a desired
Square to another side of the cube she
does a quick demo to which Jacob reacts
in astonishment saying Joey's move is
straight-up genius this is definitely a
cute moment between the three as they
pass the time with each other and enjoy
the company
Joey's captioned to the video is equally
adorable as she points out how cute and
excited her co-stars are Halloween
costumes it seems that one reason fans
are loving the IRL relationship between
Jacob oh lordy and Joey King is that
they strike a perfect balance of
adorable and hilarious avoiding the
uncomfortable over sharing cheesy traps
some couples fall into their Jack and
Sally costumes are a perfect example of
this balance in an Instagram post King
shows off the couple costume of Jack and
Sally referencing both The Nightmare
Before Christmas and Blink 182's I miss
you a manifestation of true hashtag
couple goals is just too cute for words
and the couple definitely nails the look
just when we thought it might get cheesy
King Ben boasted a follow up pic of the
couple wearing each other's costumes
it's so fun to watch these two be silly
and show us in a subtle way that they
really do seem to balance each other out
like Jack and Sally on set siestas even
the best kind of job can be tiring work
as the cast of the kissing booth shows
us however if you're surrounded by your
besties it makes getting through the day
a lot easier Joey King posted
on Instagram of her and Joel Courtney in
their characters prom attire and she's
peacefully napping on his shoulder
King captioned it a hella specific rule
about letting best friends take naps on
your shoulder while in their prom dress
this isn't the only time co-stars rely
on each other to help them catch some
Z's between takes
Joshua Edie posted a similar pic on his
Instagram but this time he's napping on
Kings shoulder it seems like this cast
support each other in a variety of ways
sharing deserts it seems like since lady
in the [ __ ] sharing food is a hallmark
of romance though they may not be eating
spaghetti king and a lordy have shared
pics of them sharing desserts and they
really are the cutest in one shot the
couple is leaning over to lick the same
ice cream cone king's caption is to
always forgive your best friend when
they buy you ice cream referencing the
all-important seventh rule the second
dessert sharing post is of King and
allure D sharing pieces of Boston cream
pie the two have their arms intertwined
in a Polaroid picture taken of them we
can tell that the chemistry between the
two definitely is not these couple posts
really are as sweet as the desserts
featured in them Dirty Dancing in
Disneyland I guess it's safe for us to
assume that allure D and King are having
the time of their life in an Instagram
post King expresses her excitement for
the kissing boot to come out the next
day and says that this elaborate dance
move shows how she and a Lordi feel
about it the reference to the movie is
appropriate as a promotional strategy
for the kissing booth that is full of
pop-culture references this couple does
a great job at drawing on what we love
most about romance and delivering it to
their fans the background is Disney's
Magic Kingdom the couple post frequently
about their theme park dates in
Disneyland and Universal Studios Jacob
oh lordy almost burnt his chickens being
a celebrity couple might sound like it's
non-stop glamour but some of the
behind-the-scenes moments showing us a
lordy and Kings relationships makes us
love them more for being so down to
earth during a live Instagram video the
couple is talking to fans and answering
questions when King explains that
they're preparing chicken for dinner
allure D's reaction to this is nothing
short of hilarity
as he realizes he forgot to check on the
chicken he rushes over to check it and
reassures king that the chicken isn't
burnt and it's actually fine this is
such a cute domestic moment that fans
got to see the live feed was viewed by
just under 1500 people who also got to
see this couple living a very relatable
life together fun in a toy store you'd
think that it was easy to feel excluded
as a younger cast member but it seems
that the cast of the kissing booth made
a real effort to make everyone feel like
part of the team
Carson white who plays Shelly's younger
brother in the movie has some pretty
cool co-stars who were ready to get in
touch with their kid selves to have fun
together in an adorable Instagram video
white shows off how he has fun with his
friends
Jacob oh lordy and Joey King in the toy
store the video shows a nerf gun duel
between white and a lordy
they both stick their tongues out and a
lordy even takes a few extra shots at a
smiling opponent you can tell how much
fun they're both having and it's so cute
to see that these co-stars have become
friends despite their age difference
behind the scenes smile there are ups
and downs in every experience and in any
relationship it's very clear that there
were an overwhelming amount of ups
during the process of filming the
kissing booth Joel Courtney posted an
adorable pic of his co-stars on
Instagram he credits Jacob allure D and
Joey King for making the past two months
of filming so memorable and so fun since
the majority of the filming took place
in South Africa members of the cast got
even closer than usual as they were all
in unfamiliar territory however it seems
like their gratitude and positive
attitude helped them bond and feel
comfortable with one another in the pic
King is hunched over a lordy and she's
holding his face in a grin she herself
is cracking up laughing the two look
like they're caught in a candid moment
that genuine happiness coupled with
Courtney's sweet post is just another
cute behind-the-scenes moment legendary
you know the cast of the kissing booth
decided to play a hashtag real game of
uno while filming the movie the
highlight of this epic game was filmed
and posted on Joel Courtney's Twitter
account it shows that Courtney got
served six draw two cards which means he
needed to add 12 cards to his hand it
also prompted us
dive into the uno rules to see if this
is allowed we ended up discovering a
rule that uno players are no era the
draw for uno card can only be played if
there are no other possible cards to
play at that time if the player who uses
this card is challenged they have to
show their entire hand if the card was
legally played than the player who
challenged it has to draw 6 cards
we're just saying it could have been
worse for Cortney Stadium kisses seeing
as Jacob allure D is Australian it's not
a given that he would be a fan of
American baseball but it turns out he is
so much so that he brought his co-star
and IRL girlfriend to a game in Joey
King's Instagram post we see two shots
of allure D kissing Kings cheek one of
them is of the two in the Boston Red Sox
Stadium and they're both wearing the
team's caps they have several posts of
moments just like this one that makes it
clear how much these to care about each
other dance rehearsal ly and LZ for
Dance Dance Revolution is such a fun
part of the movie and a quirky
characteristic of their relationship in
order to make it look convincing Joey
King and Jill Courtney had to rehearse
the dance moves over and over again it's
adorable to watch the to work on their
routine they start off strong focusing
on the moves and staying on time with
rhythm before long
they start making each other laugh and
the giggles are as cute as they are
contagious as if this is an evidence
enough of how close an adorable Courtney
and King are they participated in a pop
buzz compliment battle that makes it
super apparent that these two have a
great friendship
we'd watch these two crack each other up
over and over again birthday blasts
grand romantic gestures are clearly a
good strategy for a couple that met and
started dating on the set of a romantic
comedy the significance of this was not
lost on Joey King when she decided to
surprise her boyfriend Jacob oh lordy on
his birthday
the couple couldn't be together while
they're working in different countries
so King flew to Vancouver Canada to
surprise a lordy while he was filming
his movie the surprise was recorded on
video and it's so clear how happy and
shocked alors Diaz with his birthday
present such a super-sweet moment this
couple seems to have a bit of a thing
with birthdays as King had also posted a
say
you message to a lordy for throwing her
the pinkest and prettiest party ever
what's your favorite couple moment
between these co-stars let us know
that's all for the kissing booth behind
the scenes and cutest moments if this is
your first time visiting the things
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up
[Music]